I'm Liana Gila are coming to you live
right now with the cast of Riverdale hi
guys so for all you fans who are tuning
in right now comic-con is a little bit
of an exhausting experience no but I had
the pleasure of being with the Riverdale
cast earlier for the panel this is your
second year at comic-con what was it
like going from year one where they
hadn't seen the show and year 2 where
you guys even had cosplay people dress
it up as your characters your one was
really difficult because we had only
shot the pilot so we didn't even have
any idea what seas one would look like
and all of the questions we're about
season 1 so they'd be like so what is in
store for Veronica and we're like good
question like the girls aren't sitting
because we're women we're sitting
because their party are so bad we're
just kind of having to do with the fact
that we're women
ok believe it like not we've been we've
been together all day with a little
loopy right now so like you're huge you
know I can just like I've actually she's
all I prepped really hard for their
panel earlier in today so I couldn't but
no so what we're gonna do right now is
that for the fans who are watching right
now they weren't able to make it to your
panel so we're gonna condense it right
now and rehash all those juicy bits yeah
um starting off with the fact that we're
giving some new love interest right now
on the show I'm miss Josie um I believe
that in this Josie is gonna be getting
some love Ashley um she might be getting
a little love and the potential suitor
is Reggie mantle I was played by our new
and lovely Charles mountain he's
phenomenal okay he might be able to bet
some lashes at me
I'm coming taking that okay see you boy
kind of just went on the bus he bus
seems busted out of Riverdale here the
ship Sanju - pero I didn't know that
people could leave Riverdale but there
you go
but I understand that Kevin is gonna be
getting a new love interest this year
yeah I think at first he's gonna kind of
deal with the break-up in his own way
the bus he's a really wild year for
buses now it's very strange there is a
new Levin tryst coming in of which I
really don't I don't know who it is but
Roberto has told me that there's a new
using he's gonna be hopefully he's gonna
be a good dancer not scary certainties
whoa whoa what do you know are you
ignore those the serpent shade right I
mean my last my last level gesture not
to come up up blooding but people put
dead people with lakes and stuff so I'm
looking for someone that's maybe a
little more I have faith that not every
South Side serpent is necessarily going
to be aiding in a murder and especially
because someone here actually just got
their very own South the south side
serpent jacket Cole you put that jacket
on in the finale we get that really cute
line for Betty where she's just like
Jackie I'm sorry baby I'm with the boys
gotta go babe don't embarrass me right
now looking one sec that's moving bird
the Southside serpents you know as as
the loire are sort of opens itself up
across season two they reveal themselves
almost all of them revealed themselves
to be in compromising positions and out
of necessity do the things that they do
Chuck hasn't had the exact same position
Chuck heads morality and his conscience
are going to be tested the most
definitely throughout season two but
he's not officially a serpent when we
start this season and much of the first
part of the season is him having this
incredible dilemma like now I'm trying
to remain the conscientious objector
that he prides himself on but realizing
that perhaps he's not afforded that
luxury anymore
well we at UT actually got to break the
news that tawny topaz is coming to
Riverdale you guys are gonna get to know
her she's got some signature amazing
pink hair in the comics she's also
hinted at being bisexual and we will be
exploring that with her character on
Riverdale but what was interesting is
that earlier today Roberto said that she
could be quote trouble for the Betty and
Jughead relationship Lily how do you
have to say she's kind of she's the girl
that Jack had meets at Southside so
obviously people are gonna think that
there's a little bit of a rivalry there
and that's possible but I think we
shouldn't just set up Tony to be just a
villain you know she's a really cool
character a really cool girl I don't
think she's out to cause trouble I just
but you know things might happen Jai
could and spending a lot of time at
Southside and Betty's
I also think that people have talked
about her as a potential villain just
romantically but there's also the very
real possibility that her her kind of
siren like call for Jughead deeper into
a serpent lineage is also a kind of
trouble it has nothing to do with
romance but rather his inclusion with a
person that he finds a friend it's also
serpent right it's trouble yeah
also that bond over like loving
cheeseburgers like oh man no you guys
find someone who likes the same food as
you like you just go with it I can't
meet you and I love mac and cheese I'm
just assuming there we go cheese yeah
where did you get this idea that I look
like a juice well you're covered in I do
okay good just wanted to like make you a
little nervous that's fine you know what
I'm actually a little nervous about what
is the fact that Veronica's getting her
ex-boyfriend back into the picture I'm
excited about that are you I'm excited
about the cast you know I'm excited
about that story mm-hmm but that actual
character is trouble no like it's like
serious with drug has flashing New York
ex coming back into the picture
what does Archie have to say about that
[Music]
lift up your shirt right now it seems
like Archie yeah you probably feel a
little bit intimidated for sure but I
think his main reaction is just a fight
yeah
[Laughter]
fathers coming on to the show yes my
Consuela Mark Consuelos is a great Hyrum
he's very smooth and charming so that
kind of masks all the actual villainy
that I think is inside of him but at the
same time you know Veronica wants to
trust him
let's just see if he's worth being
trusted Cheryl I asked you this for her
meddling I asked you this about Cheryl
earlier I'm gonna ask you again
you burned your house down girl where
you living at where you living were you
you find out yeah so I might have a roof
of my not we don't know it's like the
tip dude she's a blendin there must I
mean with no speed please wait this is
she did she like Zach or Cody more I'm
telling you really really I like the
direction that this is going we're gonna
keep going oh we got to talk about the
musical moments on this show I love them
so much especially because we have such
a musically inclined cast right here
Lily when you said happy birthday
chalo chalo beautiful Betty might be
able to be an honorary pussycat actually
let me rephrase Ashley what are the
chances that Josie will let Betty me can
i rephrase that again Roberto okay I
think I mean
and he's got a lot of energy but also
it's just you know Betty sang happy
birthday wasn't like she was like you
know maybe when boots found out that you
were gonna be actually like singing were
you nervous about that aren't you and
it's like I feel like no one sounds good
singing happy I'd be surprised yeah I
was a little nerve-wracking but I guess
I was kind of like it's happy birthday
whatever but also it's not like I'm
trying to perform you know there you
love singing
I don't like singing like performing but
I actually what other musical moments
going to expect from season two I can't
speak to specifically but there is a
really lovely cover that we do in
episode 2 that was a lot of fun I was
really excited to record it and even a
little dance number that we got to do as
well is pretty awesome so one of the
things I don't know I'm sure the die
hard rubber fans know this but I was a
little bummed because madellaine wrapped
in the cover of candy girl and then I
had to get cut for time so that was in
like one episode when they were
performing in the rain and it was
awesome but so are we gonna be expecting
Cheryl to like take a mic a little bit
more this year she tossed mushrooms rap
career a yes Cheryl chops on every nail
High and she pursues a rap career please
tell me it's like bombshell blossom or
blossom bombshell that's her name
cherry
I was going off her Twitter handle okay
we do we do I think you will see us
together a little bit more and the
Pussycats will be KJ Archie was a true
artist time balancing music and football
we have your husband compartment
rebounding like in football yeah Grundy
I'm so glad is gone but now he actually
is dealing with the really serious
issues that his dad was shot what can
you tease about yeah pretty much
you we take off the first the second
season take off pretty much from where
we left off from the first one in the
diet like minute and yeah immediately
you see a different side we pretty much
are with him every step of the way of
that whole situation
and it's exciting it's exciting for me I
think you know as an actor it's kind of
the first time I've had the opportunity
to work have this kind of material like
this kind of deep kind of material so
it's challenging but she kills it well
in the season to sizzle reel that we
debuted at the panel which you can now
watch on t online we did see that it
looks like Archie is withholding some
information about that story and Jughead
really calls him out on that can you
tease a little bit like what you think
you might be hiding
um he's hiding something that he's
ashamed of some
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
anyway nobody's hiding what are you
hiding yeah yeah
so juggies have spit something you know
[Laughter]
I don't worry about anything what am I
not asked you to dnews Oh Cheryl guess
announcement of interest yeah why what
do you think okay you cheese on the
panel that Cheryl is gonna be even icier
this season no sorry the Riverdale fans
just blowing up my phone and they're
really excited that you here um you said
that Cheryl was going to even icier the
season
yes pun intended why is that and also
what is she looking for in a man orally
what you poor lately are you making
expectation I am NOT making out on
occasions or lady because I actually
wish it the hell out of that I went as
well we will see she gets colder and
meaner because of the loss but she's
been in during the last season the way
that she's been treated by her family
like the fact that no one's really there
for her and she doesn't know family
Oh didn't you hear oh okay not murdered
and then heard she got on her dad killed
him and then he committed suicide
potential yourself a little hard for her
right now good mom severely burned
welcome to heaven one parent though
she's she's for taking the reins and
she's not letting anyone else men and
what she looks for in a person I love
that what she looks for in a person who
knows Cheryl just needs love I think she
just really wants to be loved and she
don't just take it however she can get
it yeah we're gonna we're gonna keep why
don't we rein it in okay wait guys bring
him in quick question rattling yes um
when we saw that Thornhill was burning
down are you good yes that's funny when
we saw these two behind you Oh God when
we saw that Darnell was burning down
Cheryl's mom was behind her but then in
the sizzle reel that we saw she's nearly
sizzle sizzle reel saw that she looks
like she has some severe you find out
almost immediately what happened when
you are in situation
Cheryl push your mama to the fire oh
you'll see you'll say eww you guys to
the camera right now we want to say to
all the Riverdale fans who have been
tuning in who loved this show so much
and who champion for you guys to get a
full 22 episodes into we love you
I promise I'll eat some burgers okay I
promise stop yelling at me on Twitter
really no but like they were like why
isn't Jughead any more burgers he loves
burgers real burger there's a lot of
burgers and some burgers are like the
cherry on top the creme de la
it has to be a retreat really good you
guys thank you so much for staying with
us I can't pick up with the Delirium we
are we're all a little loopy but it's
been so good Roberto cast thank you so
much for something right yeah sure you
we will come up and visit you ugly
detail very honest